here are some fascinating facts about  India did you know that India produces  the most number of movies in the world  well not only do we produce amazing  movies but every single year in terms of  numbers India is the largest film  producer India houses the second highest  English-speaking community in the entire  world second to none other than the US  itself we also have the highest number  of vegetarians in the world Mosin Ram  located in mikhalaya is the wettest  region on Earth because it records the  highest amount of rainfall and did you  know that Varanasi which is one of the  oldest cities in India is almost 3000  years old well some records indicate  that it might just almost be 5000 years  old yes it's very very fascinating now  guys if there are some more amazing  facts that you'd like to share with us  here please comment down below and  subscribe to our Channel and hit the  Bell icon so that you don't miss out on  any future uploads